- Hi everyone, I'm Aimee Lee Wood,
and today we're gonna be exploring
some of your questions using mind maps.
Dost thou want a mind map?
En garde.
We're gonna do a little mind map, baby.
The first question is crumpets or ham?
This is a big question.
So this side is ham and
this side is crumpets, okay?
Ham, dead pig.
Not good.
Leading cause of global
warming, so pretty bad.
A good thing about ham is that it's tasty.
But does that really cancel out that?
I don't think so.
Crumpets on the other hand, yummy.
Butter on top, simple,
cheap, and delicious.
Oh, one thing is is that they
are a little bit fattening,
but I'm gonna stay well on
top of that, and do we care?
Oh great, post you-know-what snack.
I think crumpets is the winner.
Crumpet.
Your house is small, but
you desperately want a dog.
Do you get one?
Yeah, I get a dog.
A small dog fits in a small house,
like just don't get a big dog.
I don't think we need to do
mind map for that one, do we?
Should you follow your dreams
or study and be practical?
So this side is practical/studying, okay?
Boring.
But then when you get through
the boredom it's rewarding.
Won't last forever.
Sometimes you feel like you're
gonna be studying forever
and working your bum off forever,
but it actually will end eventually,
and you will be then able
to follow your dreams.
But some people's dreams
don't need studying, you know.
I mean went to drama school,
so I studied for three years,
which enabled me to follow my dreams,
and it definitely was
boring at times, loved it,
but it was also rewarding
and it didn't last forever.
It only lasted three
years and now look at me.
I'm following my dreams
on bloody "Sex Education."
So, conclusion, bit of both maybe, yeah?
This is should you buy a flute.
Flute purchase.
I'm gonna start this one off
with you will be like Lizzo,
if you get a flute, Lizzo,
icon, inspo, greatest human.
So that's a pretty big, big point
in the buying the flute direction.
Musical skill, always good to
have things in your toolbox.
You know, one day you're at
a party, "What can you do?"
You whip out your flute.
(imitates flute)
Everyone's like, "Oh my god,
you can play the flute."
But, expensive I think, I think
flutes are pretty expensive.
I've not looked into it
myself, but I can imagine.
Oh what was that?
Sorry, would you like to
share that with the class?
Expensive, but if you've got the money,
I think this is the main
thing you need to focus
is that it will make you more like Lizzo.
So yes, get a flute, knock yourself out.
(lofty academic music)